was so tight and i literally
could not breathe they may have looked
amazing but their experiences were worse
than you could imagine onset horror
stories about the wardrobe are all too
common you may see these actors in a
whole new light when you learn what they
went through to portray your favorite
characters
like i could i was absolutely blinded
tom holland looks great as spider-man
but he wasn't the most comfortable while
playing the web slinger the suit he wore
in homecoming was very restrictive
making it difficult to breathe zendaya
even said she was afraid the suit would
choke tom on top of this the suit made
it a hassle to drink water and use the
bathroom he had to drink through a straw
fed through one of his eye holes and had
to plan his bathroom breaks 45 minutes
in advance it looks amazing it feels
terrible black widow seems cool and
comfortable when she's taking down bad
guys but it was a different story for
scarlett johansson behind the scenes the
black widow costume was extremely tight
and hot like wearing sweaty pajamas the
heat became so bad that while filming
one scene she started hallucinating
johansson sweat so much that she would
wring her socks out at the end of the
shooting day her stunts were so
demanding that she shredded her costumes
and they had to be replaced every few
days
let me put you on hold the late chadwick
bozeman brought the black panther to
life portraying him as a stoic noble
leader while the character looks great
the black panther costume caused bozeman
some grief he felt suffocated by the
suit and it was so tight that it caused
him to have anxiety about wearing it it
is not breathable in order to
continuously wear the suit bozeman had
to get into a zen state in order to
remain calm in true bozeman fashion he
pushed through to deliver the iconic
character we now know dead
it's not the end in later movies robert
downey jr only had to wear some pads and
trackers for scenes involving iron man
suit however in the first iron man
downey donned a full ironman getup it
was a very stuffy uncomfortable and
restrictive suit when he had the helmet
on the led lights inside blinded him
luckily they didn't make him wear the
helmet for future films hey robert would
you mind putting on that helmet no yes
no gal gadot's wonder woman costume
looks amazing but it wasn't the most
comfortable to wear the corset was so
tight that gadot couldn't breathe and
she initially didn't say anything
because she was just so grateful to have
gotten the role in the first place
fortunately she got the costume loosened
for future films and was able to
continue fighting bad guys right before
i passed out they noticed that i was
breathing quite heavily christian bale
played batman for three movies and the
batsuit didn't feel as cool as it looked
he thought they should recast him during
the first movie i really did because it
was so claustrophobic that i didn't feel
like i could breathe i felt they've made
a mistake and i can't do this on top of
this he almost fainted while filming the
dark knight rises and i just put up with
it you know this is just a hell of an
honor really getting to wear this while
the beast we see on screen is completely
cgi dan stevens was actually on set
portraying the character he had to wear
a bulky suit and walk on stilts the very
physical role caused stevens to overheat
and sweat a ton subsequently leading to
weight loss i was physically
conditioning my legs to be on stilts for
12 hours a day and also conditioning the
rest of me so that i didn't waste away
to keep his weight from dipping too low
stevens had to eat a lot he stated that
he was eating up to four roast dinners a
day just to maintain his physicality
will you join me for dinner the makeup
and dressing process for vision is not
one we envy paul bettany had to wear a
skin-tight suit that extended over his
head and restricted his hearing they
eventually had to poke holes near his
ears so he could hear better on set it
takes about three and a half hours to
get into the suit but only 30 seconds to
rip it off according to betany there are
moments of such intense claustrophobia
in this thing oscar isaac had to wear an
elaborate ensemble of clothing to become
apocalypse on top of his blue makeup he
wore multiple prosthetics high-heeled
boots to push him over six feet tall and
a 40-pound suit it was hard for isaac to
move and breathe in the outfit i would
do some acting and then go to my tent
and try to breathe it was rough even
after all that isaac said the worst part
was getting it off as they had to scrape
the prosthetics off for hours apocalypse
that was excruciating catwoman is known
for wearing tight leather clothing but
it doesn't make for a comfortable
experience for the actresses that
portray the burglar when hathaway played
the character in 2012's the dark knight
rises she had a very difficult time with
the skin-tight costume it was a
challenge to breathe in and hathaway
described it as a psychological
terrorist i didn't understand how you
could be thin and strong i went into the
gym for 10 months and didn't come out
oops
ryan reynolds plays wade wilson aka the
wisecracking deadpool his suit was
nothing to laugh about though reynolds
had trouble breathing in the costume as
it was tight and hot they actually had
to redesign the first version of the
costume because it was way too tight for
reynold's body which he got in shape for
the movie i'm always so terrified i'll
like throw up in the mask or something
you know there's no space in that thing
at all
is the mask muffling my voice the live
action grinch movie starring jim carrey
has impressive makeup and costumes it
took eight hours to apply carrie's full
body makeup prosthetics and costume
which he described as being buried alive
each day he went through this grueling
process 92 times during the course of
filming the christmas flick they
actually brought in a cia operative to
train carrie to cope with torture so he
could continue playing the character
without having a complete meltdown and i
went back to my trailer and put my leg
through the wall and i told ron howard i
couldn't do the movie the winter
soldier's outfit may not seem like it's
too bad to wear but sebastian stan is
here to tell you otherwise the mask he
had to wear for most of the movie was
extremely restrictive to his breathing
to the point where he almost passed out
they shot a lot of his fight scenes in
june and july in the heat which made
things much worse i would just have to
literally rip it off my face and just
breathe so i gotta know how to breathe
right we already talked about one
catwoman so let's discuss another that
had a less than ideal costume michelle
pfeiffer played the character in 1992's
batman returns her iconic leather suit
was extremely problematic for pfeiffer
to wear and she said it was the most
uncomfortable costume she had ever worn
the face mask was smashing my face and
choking me to get the suit as tight as
it was they actually vacuum sealed it
onto pfeiffer meow margot robbie's
harley quinn is one of the dceu's most
popular characters we first saw her in
2016's suicide squad where she sported a
ripped t-shirt and very short shorts
robbie said she didn't like the costume
as it made her self-conscious on top of
this the tight shorts made it difficult
to eat and the t-shirt would get wet and
uncomfortably cling to her body director
david ayer didn't think denim overalls
would be appropriate for that character
luckily for margo she was able to ditch
these clothes in later films and was
just as amazing in the role
what although we like to imagine
ourselves in our favorite characters
outfit we don't envy these actors at all
despite how uncomfortable and difficult
it was they pushed through to deliver
performances that made it all worth it
so the next time you see a character
with an awesome costume on the big
screen consider what they had to go
through on set which costume do you
think would be the worst to wear